have you made more than $10 million in
your career are you jealous of my hair
there was some deception there do you
like Andrea bz do you think my book is
good Jesus oh my God how's that for
honesty do you pee in the shower uh have
you ever felt jealous that I'm more
famous than you do you currently feel
like you're being held against your will
yes don't do this don't don't try this
at
[Music]
home
we are here in a mysterious setting go
ahead Sir with a mysterious man tell me
sir what is your name David Robins is my
name how does one become a lie detector
man I was with the police when I was
sent for training at the Canadian police
college and it's on one of the first
polygraph courses that they had there
wow when I retired as started doing it
privately wow I would assume you've done
more important things than a lie
detector test while people play chess
then tests on murders sexual assaults
robberies so slightly more important
than chess just barely no no this really
important okay well Levy um I'm going
under the under the detector first yeah
and I'm nervous I'm nervous too I can I
feel like I'm already going to set it
off I've always wanted to do one of
these one cuz I wanted to see if I could
trick it for myself just know and two I
don't know cuz I'm a little bit of a
mass kiss who enjoys oh it's already
moving it's moving when I do things man
so what kind of questions are you going
to ask me that's the question some
personal some about me some about Magnus
some about Hikaru some about Hans NE
no I will address the uh that that
currently there is a documentary being
made I am not allowed to say with who
when it's coming out but we will not be
getting into questions about Hans Neeman
because of that so for all of you fans
who are now freaking out about that that
is the only reason we're not getting
into those questions you've already seen
us address things pretty clearly so a
lie it's a lie it's a lie if I take a
deep breath does that make it look like
I'm lying no cuz I I'm definitely a deep
breather when I have anxiety I think me
too oh let's turn into a therapy session
I did by the way we're also going to
play chess with 10 minutes on the clock
um uh maybe we should oh you can't move
the hand so we'll shake hands be a
little shake hands handshake I'm going
to start your clock cuz I'm black I feel
like we've had a lot of games D I'll
play
D4 okay and um my question is is your
full name Daniel
wrench my full name is Daniel Michael
Wrench It was changed when I was a kid
it was Daniel Joseph Cordon Samson lot
of divorces I'm giving you way too much
information is he lying
well that was a lie when he said too
much
information that's true because there's
a lot more to it than that not even the
beginning of the information wow love
that are you about to take a lie
detector test I am I'm going to run out
of time I'm like having I was I was
willing for that was that when I said I
am that was true it was true but CHS
you're a little bit nervous about it
yeah I am nervous oh wow okay let's just
get um right into it Kenny
um do you think my book is
good I haven't read your
book damn you should have just said
yes is that true well we definitely know
that's
true all right okay okay he the book
just came out you got to give me some
time you're also too strong for the book
Thank you um speaking of strength do you
think you're better at chess than me I
do think I'm better at chess than you
damn
little bit of activity
there this is so good it's funny cuz I
feel like I need to be honest like I
feel like I had to say yes to that I
actually don't know that I'm better than
yeah well you know we're chess players
we got we're chess players I think that
was probably more honest answer like I
actually don't know do you pee in the
shower I pee in the shower often I I
think people are demented if they don't
I mean you at least once in your life
you save water I don't know about all
that but you just just there it's all
water it's warm on your skin you get do
do people get out and pee in the toilet
and get back in the shower that just
seems like is anybody out there doing
that does anybody shower do I PE in
theer I don't obviously okay I'm just
checking I don't know what's going on
I'm fascinated by the whole thing are
you jealous of my
hair I'm jealous of everyone's hair cuz
my hair is receding anding but look at
this you really jealous I mean
that's wow okay have you ever liked your
own social media posts with chess.com
official account yes
wow that was that was fast that was I
think it's part of business I would say
this I also do it way less often than
I'm accused of ah like people think I
run the social media like I don't I
don't run chess.com social media no
problem it's all true right yes sir take
that haters have you ever rooted against
Magnus in a world championship
match I don't think so I think I've
always rooted for even against f I'm I'm
that's interesting if I'm telling the
truth on that I think I I think I'm
always rooting for Magnus actually and I
can tell you why cuz I think I think
Magnus is good for the game even when
Magnus was playing Fabiano who was an
American I think I was probably in my
deepest of Hearts rooting for the
biggest star okay and I think I was
probably I love fabbi I love Fabby Fab's
a
friend but I think objectively I felt
like Magnus was still the most important
figure in the game and this is even when
he was at a separate apparently
competing rival company right so I've
always rooted for Magnus yes pretty much
um when you first were asked have you
always rooted for him you there was some
deception there but you explained that
later would you let your children pursue
a career as professional chess players
if they were interested yes I would
looks good all right sure do you think
you're the best chess commentator on
step wow I I would say
[Music]
yes there no deception there confidence
is I think it's funny cuz I I
legitimately think that everybody is so
good I think Robert Hess is
phenomenal I think you're amazing I
think Don is amazing I don't get to do
commentary as much as I it's almost like
ranking your kids right but I I do think
I I do think I'm pretty good at it if
you're the best do you think I'm the
second best chess commentator in the
game I actually don't I don't think
you're the second best I also don't
think I'm the second best maybe Recaps
but live you are live I I don't think
you are the most entertaining Creator in
the game by far I actually agree I'm not
offended by that I always say I'm I say
the same thing I I was about to move the
Rook with my right hand and I really I
can't do that so uh have you ever felt
jealous that I'm more famous than you I
have
Jesus oh my God that was uh I feel super
proud of you honestly I feel like I've
had a a hand in helping you as much as
and I think you've I think you've with
your success you've always been super
gracious and humble and thankful but
I'll be honest like there was a there
was a Crossroads in my career where I
consciously chose to take a back seat to
help what you want to call it platform
position Spotlight others and as some of
them have become very successful there's
a part of me that has been jealous and
it's it's stung a little bit because I I
also love you know me I love content I
love creating and I think I'm pretty
good at it and I think I have a vision
for it but I also feel now I'm going to
get emotional I feel super proud and but
I have been jealous at times how's that
for honesty that's good well I will say
I have uh wow this is like a real
therapy session I was to say I I I I
have uh nothing but respect and uh
admiration and I I definitely feel like
in the chess content game I stand on
shoulders of giants like you and Robert
doing speed chess whatever the hell it
was called speed chess challenge in 2017
back in the day yeah that was uh that
was wild I don't feel that way about
about everybody but we've had
conversations about all of this would
you feel comfortable leaving me in your
house
alone yeah I would I wouldn't steal
anything probably I don't know I've
never been tempted but who knows it was
a that question made me a little nervous
cuz I I definitely get nervous with my
my my wife and I are not big on people
watching our kids who we don't know like
so it actually makes it so we travel
less and enjoy our life less cuz we're
just don't hire babysitters so work from
family well this would be I would be by
myself you guys would be on I'll house
it okay oh I would I would I would
totally be good with that hell man you
could go full McColly culan at my house
how did I just give up A7 and not even
think that that was a bad idea I think
the thing affects our chest I as soon as
you start hitting me with the really
really o the really really o my my chest
went sorry I'm not trying to spike it
moving over my right hand here I'm
supposed to keep my right hand still
have you ever shoplifted as a child I
have I stole I stole from a store
actually for many months a particular
store eventually got caught which was
great it was actually a really good
thing I think you need to do all the
stupid stuff in I think everybody has to
do stupid stuff in life otherwise I mean
maybe some people are angels but you uh
you got to do a lot of dumb stuff and
then you got to grow out of it that's
what I believe you got to get it all out
early later it goes the harsher the
consequences so have you ever thought in
the last few years that this was it and
chess popularity has peaked honestly
like I might be
the the the
blind whatever just like hopeless
dreamer but the answer is no no like
I've always thought that we have more to
go I've had fears of being wrong and and
as the stakes have gotten higher with
our company and and we've grown and
we've oh my God I get anxiety thinking
we have more almost 800 people now like
you know there's a lot I definitely feel
heavier and I feel the weight of what
we've done to deliver on those promises
probably more than I ever have and I
don't know that that's great for my
health and stress at times that's the
truth but I have never doubted what
chess was going to become and uh I've
been lucky to be right about some things
that other people thought I was wrong
about and I hope it continues so we'll
see is cheating on chess.com
worse or better than than the public
thinks I think it's better than the
public thinks no deception do you
secretly wish you were a grandm are you
on satisfied being an I am I am I wish I
was a grandm I do who doesn't you work
super hard for something you know and
everyone has their story of how they
didn't get the lucky break or this or
that you know and obviously I'm very
grateful for my life but yeah of course
I wish I was a GM who doesn't you and I
should start like an honesty podcast
chess podcast let's do podast I feel
like I's Danny and Levy that would
actually be probably that would probably
be pretty popular actually now that
we're here have you ever pretended to
understand a conversation about Chess
just to fit in yes for sure with with
which players I've done it at times
where like I also like didn't quite hear
what was being discussed and so then I
tried to like jump in I've uh I've done
it when yeah I wanted to just pretend
like I understood the idea I just like
when you're around super GMS I think for
the most part like fully C and follow
everything but I think at times you know
you're like oh or like you feel like it'
be socially awkward to make them slow
down for you so so you don't yeah make
them slow down for you have you ever
worn sunglasses inside to look cool
yes what a dork he is he's a dork that's
who I am that's who I am um is that true
oh he's tell them the
truth the the most confident answer so
far about both doing it and being a dork
is Magnus Carlson the coolest world
champion we've ever had it's not even
close he's the coolest world champion
we've ever had I love dingly Ren by the
way I'm so stable this is just pure
honesty I mean I'm I I didn't come here
to lie oh I I kind of now we're having a
problem oh okay I said I don't want to
come here to lie there we go it's the
accent it's the whole I love that I love
that okay this isn't good for me right I
don't think so it's a bit of a Shaban
move there Shaban with things on my
fingers you're going to see man this is
hard oh I I'm I'm yeah I I imagine wait
I can I catch you I'm in the Box I'm in
the Box I'm not in the Box because I
forgot okay I resigned I resigned we can
fiz with that there we go that was fun
with switch colors and put Levy under
under the microscope don't do this don't
don't try this at home I'm excited
we're going to grill him we're going to
grill him love are you about to take a
light detector test yes are both of
those things true good luck Danny yes
game on I guess he would have to say yes
otherwise that would be game on do you
think you're a better chess player than
me oh we're start we're starting oh wow
you're just throwing it right back to me
yes
unequivocally I think I'm a better chess
player than a lot of people who I'm not
higher rated
than see a lot of increase in blood
pressure okay I'm staring over there to
see the answer okay does that mean this
is good does that mean I mean there's a
little deception indicated oh wow I
don't even know I'm lying I think I
think you're trying to pump up yourself
maybe oh I'm not trying to do anything
I'm probably just thing just probably
scaring me would you rather be competing
in events than covering them
no you love covering them yeah yeah it's
truthful have you ever
considered quitting your your chess
Creator career to pursue another career
maybe but not anytime
soon but you have thought about it yeah
of
course have you ever pretended to know a
celebrity even though you've never
actually met them I don't no I don't
think so why why would I ever do that I
don't know just
asking don't see anything there okay
okay that's good enough maybe there you
go I love it are you afraid to chess
box yes yes depends on the yes do you
like Andrea
bz yes kind a little bit as I mean you
know just he's not terrible what is he
lying on that well not when he says he's
not
[Laughter]
terrible so good she's not terrible you
know could be worse people do you ever
get your feelings hurt by YouTube
comments never TR hold on that do you
get ever get your feelings hurt by any
social media comments toward you no not
really have you made more than $1
million in your
career I don't think
so
no that's truful response all right okay
this thing can't get me I'm just so Zen
just love chess so much I'm just were
you nervous meeting Magnus no absolutely
not I think he was I think he was I
think he was too I knew he was okay but
I you know I feel like that that when I
like publicly stated I was nervous you
know I today was better though the
second day I I I relaxed a bit Danny
when I had to ask Magnus a question and
I I had them in my ear like Levy's got
the next question and he was answering
this question my heart has never pounded
that I don't know why I was like damn
that's like magnet all the top players
you know I will admit like we've I've
gotten to a place I I'm not on there but
we'll assume I'm being truthful like
where that doesn't happen to me anymore
but I think I've done more Magnus
interviews at this point than like
anybody but I'll say it took a long time
he's an intimidating interview and he's
the goat do you think your YouTube
content is too click baity
yes no deception there oh wow okay
Twitter trolls win I guess yeah the ones
that hurt my feelings or didn't I don't
know that question will make so do you
think you'd beat me in chess
boxing with the right preparation yes
what do we got over there boss he's got
a problem there you got a
problem okay I love that okay I don't
you answer the question yeah I did not
think I so good so good literally would
not no no no no small problem or big
problem like guess big no big sh yeah I
did not I do you do you like your own
YouTube videos like do I physically
click like on them yeah in the beginning
actually you know like I go back two
years and sometimes I did like one of my
own videos but but not no not anymore
not anymore no do you think I'm
funny yeah yeah yeah why not ah
deception there that's that's bull that
no way I
think maybe I got nervous looking at you
okay okay I think you're funny do do you
think I'm the best chess commentator
at chess.com
no no I think it's Robert Hess I don't
see any deception there yeah that
doesn't mean you're not the second best
but I always say it's I love the honesty
we have a great honest conversation
ditsky but yeah do you think you're the
most influential chess Creator in the
world well that's an easy yes the better
question is am I the most influential
figure in chess
ever and I don't think so I mean I think
it's probably Ma or if you just look at
numbers maybe Anand when he said um
about himself
there's quite a reaction there oh maybe
I do deep down meaning I meaning it says
I'm lying and I actually do think I'm
the most influential maybe maybe therapy
can unlock that yeah have you ever used
a a slang or a trendy phrase you didn't
really understand just to make your
content sound
cooler no what Riz I don't I don't think
so no I mean if I did then I really need
to unpack lies to myself in
therapy there no no deception okay thank
the answer to me would have been yes I
have you oh no I have well you you're a
dad also I got to stay I got a few more
years and then I'm then I'm cooked there
you go slang right there cooked have you
ever used your chess skills to flirt
with
anyone maybe my wife I don't know I I've
not to my memory but this thing is about
to tell me I did so he did didn't he he
did come on oh
yeah I love it yeah I I I used to hide
that I was a chess player so who knows
yeah I'm going to just say was have you
ever wanted to ban another chess Creator
from your Twitch chat
maybe Hikaru no the B maybe the bz I
don't know actually uh I don't think I
have but again I'm at the mercy of this
device so there is some deception
indicated this a little bit though right
yeah I guess maybe I maybe I have had
that are you satisfied not being a GM it
is a coping mechanism for me to tell
myself that I will be a Grandmaster one
day but I'm definitely not satisfied not
being a GM it
hurts it's truthful are you in any group
chats with Hikaru
Nakamura not that I know
of what no do do you currently feel like
you're being held against your will here
yeah
yes would never volunteer for
this is that truthful
yes did you ever shoplift as a
kid yeah yeah oh yeah Yu-Gi-Oh cards
Yu-Gi-Oh cards yeah from Blockbuster and
one time I stole display bottle of
cologne that was like 75% finished CU my
parents wouldn't buy me any of the cool
Brands like aeropostal or abomi do you
like online chess more than over
theboard that's a good question actually
I don't know what it's going to pop up I
think I like online competition more cuz
I don't like to travel I think I get
very stressed over the board but social
stuff like social settings I I mean
there's no nothing really beats this
hanging out with friends drinking I
almost played Queen F4 that would have
been really bad have you spent too much
money on clothes
uh my wife would say yes I would
disagree
but I don't spend much money I like to
invest things but I think my biggest
expense is probably close like this
sweater maybe of all the things my
family did not do right raising me they
taught me how to budget money is that
too deep for this video are you going to
write a second
book
yes no plans to yet but I'd like to
do you ever get jealous of me I don't
get jealous of anybody
actually little problem there little
problem really huh probably get jealous
a little bit a little bit of someone
about something you know what I'm going
to I'm going to can you play Rook takes
spawn I'm going to amend that and say
I've definitely gotten jealous but I
don't think I'm jealous of people I
think I'm jealous of like if I find
someone in a cool collab or situation I
go what the hell how'd that happen yeah
so I definitely felt the EM you get fomo
about opportunities like you get you get
jealous about opportunities and cool
things that you want to be a part of
yeah and that's why it's not happening
for me cuz I guess I think I deserve it
right so not jealous of people but you
want to be appreciated for opportunities
you don't want to be left out I think
the people that I work with I don't have
a dedicated team so my whole career as a
content creator I feel like I have not
been prioritized as a
client and it has prevented me from
getting very cool things so I'm trying
to control it more are you happy the
cheating scandal
happened
yes is that true yeah yeah views I was
very careful in the beginning of the
cheating scandal because in the back of
my mind I thought what if Hans sues
everybody which is why I did
not you know I let it sit a little bit
that tip to me and Hikaru I well Hikaru
started real fast he was you know play
like Rook B4 and then we can agree to a
draw yeah yeah I was just about to offer
you a draw oh yeah a mercy draw cuz I'm
not going to flag a man who only has 10
seconds and a strap ask me one final
question draw
agreed are you happy that you won our
match yeah but I think you lost on
purpose in the first game the world will
never know I feel like you could have
defended much more tenaciously but I
think you you you gave it to me a little
bit but we do that sometimes like for
Content it's subconscious it's actually
funny cuz while we were playing the game
I was about to say something like if you
asked me whether I want to win more or
see you win actually I was going to say
I'd rather you win I actually think it's
better for content and I was purposely a
little bit it's I was thinking about
that I I do that all the time I've shot
on uh like for Wired before they make me
play people and I can't I can't get into
it all of a sudden I'm losing so even
against in chess with James like out of
nowhere I'm just completely lost and I'm
fine with it for Content but it's I'm
like damn I kind of want to win wish I
had that Killer Instinct but that's
funny I I don't I don't anymore but this
has been great let's let's go let's go
get a drink me and you how about that
yeah am I still connected can I say one
last thing sure I really hope this is
true because I I do mean it I think of
everybody in the Chess World I look up
to you the
most wow that's pretty straightforward
that means a lot to me yeah thank you
man
appreciate that
yeah